As soon as you tell me
I can't do something,
I'm going to do it.
I hope that in
sharing with you what
I've learned over 50 years
of writing that it will help
you find your way as a writer.
As a 12-year-old, I was
obsessed by the idea of growing
breasts and getting my period.
But there was no place
that I could read about it.
When I started to write, I
was determined to be honest.
So I'm going to share with you
the practical side of writing.
There's nothing more
important than character.
You're living with
these people for years.
You had better feel for them.
Do some exercises.
Have your character
write a letter to you.
The first draft is
pure torture for me.
I hate every second of it.
I have a messy
mind, and my writing
is a process of
cleaning up the mess,
then slowly making a story.
I will be able to
show that to you.
I got a particularly
nasty review once.
It got to me, and I
took my typewriter,
and I held it over
this arroyo.
And I was going to throw it in.
I thought I cannot
do this anymore.
And then this little
voice went off in my head.
Wait, you're going to let
this one review stop you
from writing?
That's crazy!
That's one opinion.
I enjoy finding and
supporting new writers,
and this is a chance for
me to reach more of you.
I always ask myself,
why would anyone
write if they didn't have to?
I mean it's so hard.
So this is for all of you
who feel that you have to.
I'm Judy Blume, and
this is my Master Class.